The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: So in
the previous lecture,
I told you about
many electron atoms.
And in order to describe
their structure,
we have to build a
Slater determinant,
because that builds
in the antisymmetry
between all pairs of orbitals.
Now, Slater determinants
are expanded
into a very large number
of additive terms.
And there are algebraic
methods, which
I describe in a
supplement, which
enable you to reduce these
algebraic terms, the sum
over an enormous
number of terms,
to something almost identical
to what you would get
if you didn't antisymmetrize.
They're just a few extra things.
And so once you know the
mechanics, it's not a big deal.
It's a little bit more
work than just calculating
the individual orbital
matrix elements,
but it's nothing special.
And Henry has produced
a beautiful thing,
a beautiful handout on
Slater-Condon parameters,
which is what you get when
you evaluate these Slater
determinal matrix elements.
And they are the things
that you use to describe
electronic structure.
So electronic structure
is a really complicated
many electron descriptive thing.
But if you can reduce for
every atom to a small number
of parameters, most of which
you understand intuitively
how they depend on
properties of the atom,
like the ionization energy
of the individual orbitals,
you can say, yes, I understand
all of the periodic table.
That's where it comes from.
The rules enable you to
identify the lowest lying states
and to calculate
their properties
and to be able to
intuit their properties
and to be aware of when
something unexpected happens,
which is what we're
always looking
for as physical chemists.
We're always looking for
a simple minded picture
that breaks.
Because then we can go
deeper into our understanding
of all the pieces.
But we're always parameterizing.
OK.
So there's a lot of subtleties
that I didn't have time
to talk about in the evaluation
of these Slater determinal
matrix elements.
And since whatever
problems I give
you connected with Slater
determinal matrix elements
or Slater determinants are
going to be really simple.
They're probably going
to be 2 by 2 or 3 by 3.
You don't really need
to know and understand
all the rules and
all the shortcuts.
But you've got the
basic mechanism.
So a Hamiltonian
doesn't depend on spins.
But because of antisymmetry,
the spatial part
of the wave function does depend
on which spin state you've got.
And so the Hamiltonian
knows about spins
in a peculiar, indirect
way, which is beautiful.
You've got to admire how
clever this Hamiltonian is
to be able to capture
these spin effects.
And of course, you have
to capture them too.
All right.
So today we're finally
getting to molecules.
And the simplest molecule
is the homonuclear molecule.
Two hydrogens with one electron.
That's the simplest problem.
And because it is
representative of all
of the qualitative
effects and most
of the quantitative
calculations you do,
it's a really
great introduction,
because it captures most
of the important stuff
that molecules or
small molecules
do, that the electronic
structure of small molecule.
So the key to being able to
describe small molecules using
this LCAO, Linear Combination
of Atomic Orbitals method,
is the variational method.
And this variational
method says,
we're going to throw a whole
bunch of basis functions
at the problem.
A whole bunch of orbitals, which
we choose because we like them
or because the
computer likes them.
And we find that the
linear combination
of coefficients
of these orbitals
that minimizes the energy.
And you can do this in wave
mechanics or matrix mechanics.
It's more elegant
in matrix mechanics,
and you should be comfortable
going from one to the other.
Now, I'm only going to be
talking about a 2 by 2 problem.
So you can go easily
from one to the other
without even taking a breath.
But anyway, OK.
In approaching
this, you're going
to see what's called the
general eigenvalue problem where
instead of diagonalizing
a simple matrix,
you have to deal with
the Hamiltonian matrix
and an overlap
matrix, which makes
the solution of the
secular equation,
finding the eigenvalues and
eigenstates a little bit more
complicated.
So you're going to see
it first appear here.
And it can be solved
by a simple matrix
equation, which is in a
supplement to a later set
of lecture notes.
But this is the thing that
consumes the vast majority
of computer time in
maybe in the world,
but certainly among chemists.
So the crucial thing, and
I wrote it all in caps,
in dealing with this
complicated many body problem,
we make a crucial assumption.
And that's called the
Born-Oppenheimer approximation.
It's based on the fact that
electrons move really fast
and nuclei move really
slowly relative to electrons.
And so what we do is
we solve the problem
with the nuclei clamped.
Because that's a
good approximation.
And then after we solve
the electronic problem,
we have what we call a
potential energy surface, which
is the electronic energy as a
function of nuclear coordinate.
And it's parametric.
But then once we have the
potential energy surface,
we can calculate the
rotation and vibration.
So basically, what
we're doing in making
the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation is
we're setting up to treat
vibration and rotation
by perturbation theory.
Now, you never see it
mentioned in that way,
but that is, in fact,
what we're doing.
And the reason we
can get away with it
is the difference in velocity
of electrons versus nuclei.
But it's a fundamental
philosophical point of view
that we take about
molecular structure
that we can clamp the nuclei,
get most of the insight,
and then allow the nuclei
to move and the electrons
with them and calculate
everything else.
So this is central to
chemistry, the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation.
Without that, we would
have a bag of atoms.
And that would be a
very bad starting point,
because we believe in bonds.
And a bag of atoms is
saying, well, yeah,
we could be statistical.
We could say every atom is
capable of being anywhere
and they don't interact
in any rational way,
and we would have no insight.
So this is where most of
the ideas that you learn
to use as physical chemists and
probably any kind of chemist
comes from the
Born-Oppenheimer approximation.
And it's widely misunderstood
and misrepresented.
But we won't go into that.
OK, we're going to derive two
orbitals for hydrogen. H2 plus.
The sigma bonding orbital
and the sigma star
anti-bonding orbital.
This is enough to
basically understand
how you get bonding and
anti-bonding in any molecule.
And I like to say
that we understand
bonding in a very simple way.
If you have wave functions
for two adjacent atoms
and they overlap in the
region between the two nuclei,
you get constructive
interference,
you get twice as much
amplitude in the region
where the electrons interact
with both nuclei, which means
four times the probability.
So a little bit of overlap
leads to a big energy
effect because of this
constructive interference.
And that's really,
really important.
And all sorts of
hand waving arguments
about what makes a chemical
bond have a lot of currency,
even here at MIT, but
that's what a bond is.
It's constructive interference.
All right, so let's get started.
And the lecture notes are
extremely long and extremely
beautiful and clear.
They're written by Troy.
I have reduced them
to a minimal picture,
but I don't want to
detract from them.
The insight is very rich.
OK, so what we
have to do first is
to look at a coordinate system.
So we have one hydrogen nucleus.
Another one.
There's a center of mass.
And so we say we have RA, this
vector from the center mass
to this RB like that.
And up here is the electron.
And it's at position R.
This is at position RB.
Position RA.
Now, the center of mass
can be anywhere in space,
and we don't really care.
So we tend to not talk about
where the center of mass is.
But there is another set
of coordinates for it.
OK.
And now we have this,
which is called R sub A.
And it's a vector.
And this is R sub B. So
we have uppercase symbols
for nuclear positions and
lowercase for electrons,
except they're between
electrons and nuclei.
OK.
And once we have
this picture, we
can write what the Hamiltonian
is, because we're basically
looking at the interactions
between these three particles.
And so we have kinetic energy
and we have potential energy.
And the Hamiltonian-- excuse me.
--in atomic units
is this del squared,
which is the second derivatives
with respect to whatever we
have here, which is little r.
And we have 1/2.
It's 1/2 because of atomic
units and because the mass
of the electron
is treated as one.
And then we have a similar sort
of term for del for nucleus A.
And we have a two, because
1/2 in atomic units.
But we have the mass of
A. Now, the minus signs,
why do we have minus signs here?
You know this.
AUDIENCE: This is
the Schrodinger.
ROBERT FIELD: Yeah, right.
Or we say it's p
squared over 2m.
And p is-- right.
OK, but what we're trying
to understand stuff,
this is negative.
That means it sort of
leads to a stabilization.
And many people talk about
bonding in terms of velocity
or momentum, but I don't.
And then we have
del squared B over 2
and B and then a repulsion term.
A whole bunch of
terms that we have.
So these are the
kinetic energy terms.
And then we have the
potential energy terms.
1 over RA vector minus little
r vector minus 1 over RB
minus little r.
And then the repulsion
between RA minus RB.
OK, that's it.
Now, that's a lot of stuff.
And we'd like to make
a lot of it go away.
But again, we have potential.
We have kinetic energy and
we have potential energy.
So as I've written
it, the Hamiltonian,
which is our big
problem, is a function
of ra rb r big RA big RB.
That's just ridiculous.
We don't want to look
at a function of all
these variables.
We would like to be
able to simplify it
so that we can draw pictures
on a two dimensional surface
or just to reduce it now.
We like to think in terms
of orders of magnitude.
And so it is a very
simple matter to say,
well, let's simplify
this Hamiltonian
by clamping the nuclei.
They don't move.
If they don't move, then the
big Rs are no longer operators.
They're just parameters.
And the contributions
to the kinetic energy
of the heavy particles gone.
So there's no rotation
and no vibration.
Now, it doesn't go away.
We have to come back with it.
But we come back
with it when we have
a good representation of
the electronic structure
for the nuclei clamped.
And if we can do it for one
internuclear separation,
we can do it for all
internuclear separations.
And so if you have a
grid of say 1,000 points,
you do the same calculation
1,000 times, except you don't.
Because you know how
to extrapolate from one
point to another.
But basically, you are
thinking about this
as the problem of finding
the electronic wave
function at a grid of points.
And so that turns all of the
big R's into parameters, not
operators, and simplifies
the problem enormously.
And so the reduced
Hamiltonian becomes--
we'll call it the
electronic Hamiltonian.
R semicolon ra rb.
So r is the variable, and
these are just parameters
that we sometimes include.
And then the Hamiltonian is
just del squared little r over 2
plus V effective.
And this would be as a
function of RA and RB.
But it's because
of R approximation,
it's just a function
of R. So these we pick.
And this is the thing
that we're worrying about.
And then there's the
1 over RA minus RB,
which is just a constant.
This is the repulsion between
two charged particles.
So this is a lot nicer.
We can also sort of
forget about this.
I mean, it's there, but
it's a trivial thing
that we can add in.
So we have basically the
kind of problem we like.
A kinetic energy problem and
a potential energy problem.
So we're going to
take this approach
and we're going to
learn how to apply it
to the simplest system.
And the simplest
system is homonuclear.
That's better than
heteronuclear,
because if we had
two different atoms,
we'd have to somehow represent
their difference in properties.
But because it's homonuclear,
we just basically
have an atom, the
same atom, repeated,
and there's a lot of
symmetry that results.
And the other is
only two electrons.
I mean, sorry,
only one electron.
Remember, we did hydrogen
first, and that was wonderful.
We got everything that was--
basically everything is
related to anything else.
Any property is related to any
other property of the hydrogen
atom through this
orbital approximation.
And so one electron makes
us feel really comfortable,
because we are going
to expect that there
is some structure, which
means not just a random number
or random collection of
descriptive observations
but some relationships.
And we don't have to
even antisymmetrize.
So it's really something
we can hit out of a park
without getting too stressed.
But there is a
problem, and that is,
how do we find the
wave functions if we
take a simple basis set?
1s a plus 1s b.
So these are hydrogenic
wave functions.
We know them.
Now, they may not be the
most convenient thing
when you're doing a
large scale calculation.
In fact, nobody uses
hydrogenic functions,
even though they
make a lot of sense,
because they're not
computationally as
easy as Gaussian functions.
So if you need to describe
a problem with, say, 10
hydrogenic functions
and 1,000 Gaussians,
you're way ahead of the game
when you use 1,000 Gaussians,
because the integrals
are trivial.
But in terms of
understanding, it's
really nice to take things
we know and do everything
in terms of them.
OK.
And so this is where
we get the variational.
So what we do is
we say we're going
to express the wave function
as a linear combination
of atomic orbitals.
And that means we can
adjust the coefficient
of each atomic orbital
to minimize the energy.
And the variational principle
or the variational theorem
says, no matter what
you do, you can't
calculate an energy
lower than the lowest
energy of the system.
Even if you don't
know what it is,
you know that
anything you calculate
is a little bit higher.
And what you want
to do, then, is
to make the energy as small
as possible by doing a min max
problem on the coefficients.
And so the variational
method is basically that.
OK.
So basis set.
I'm probably not going to finish
my notes, even though these
are a massively reduced version
of what Troy had written,
because I have some
other things to say
that aren't in the notes,
and they're really important.
When we do perturbation
theory, we implicitly
are dealing with an infinite
basis set and an infinite set
of known matrix elements.
But we can't ask a computer to
diagonalize an infinite matrix.
So we have a tricky
way of doing this
so that we can use
perturbation theory
to get a good approximation
of almost anything you want.
But if your basis set
is really terrible,
then the perturbation theory
is going to be terrible too.
I mean, it's going to
give correct answers.
You're just going to have
to do more calculations.
The variational
method says, OK, let's
choose not an infinite basis
set but a physically appropriate
basis set or a computationally
minimal basis set.
And so we are making
decisions about form and size.
So we can use
hydrogenic orbitals,
because we know what they are.
We know how to evaluate
lots of integrals with them
without too much trouble.
And how many?
Well, we've got two atoms.
And so you sort of need
one orbital on one atom
and one orbital on
another to even begin
to capture the molecularness
of the problem.
So we've chosen the simplest
possible form but not
necessarily the most
convenient form.
And the size is two.
Now, we could use four.
We could use 100.
And you could use a million.
Most quantum chemical
calculations,
which you're going
to be doing soon,
involve not just
millions but often
billions of basis functions.
And the computer
does all the work
and doesn't complain to you.
It doesn't require a trip to
the beach or anything like that.
It just says, OK, here is
what you wanted me to do.
I don't know whether you--
it's a stupid question
or a smart question, but I'm
answering not what you thought
you asked but what you did ask.
OK.
But we're going to show how
it works with the simplest
possible basis set.
So our electronic
wave function will
be a function of
electron position
and parametrically
nuclear position.
C1, 1S A R R. I'm
going to stop including
this parametrically dependent on
R. But eventually I'll do that.
But for now.
OK, so that's the wave function.
The variational function.
And we need to be able to
calculate the average energy,
because we know the average
energy is going to be larger
than the true energy.
But if we do a good
calculation, the energy
difference between the
truth and what you get
is small as possible.
And so you can say for a
particular basis that we have,
the best possible energies,
if you want to do better,
you have to use a bigger
or smarter basis set.
And so how do we calculate
the average energy?
Well, we do the
usual thing where
you say psi H psi d tau
over psi star psi d tau.
Now, I'm including
this because we need it
when we don't have
orthonormal basis functions.
And for this basis set,
they're not orthonormal.
They can't be.
The wave functions for one atom
are all mutually orthogonal.
But because you have
two atoms and there's
overlap between them,
they are not orthogonal,
and they're not normalized.
And so we have to do this.
And so the problem is
we want to minimize
the energy with respect to C1
or C2 or C1 star or C2 star.
Now, this is a subtle point.
The complex conjugate of C
is linearly independent of C.
But they're related
to each other.
And so you can say that
these derivatives are 0,
and you can choose C1 and
C2 or C1 star and C2 star,
and you get the same
result. And so it's
important to understand this.
So this is all by
means of introduction.
I'm going to start
repeating myself.
But let's draw some pictures.
So the complicated
thing is the potential.
And so to illustrate
the R dependence,
I'm going to try to draw things.
So we have r small and R large.
This is the positions
of the nuclei.
And the potential
will look like this.
So the potential goes
to minus infinity
at the position of the
nucleus, because the electron
is attracted to the nucleus.
And when the distance
is 0, we have an--
it's a forgivable
infinity because it--
anyway.
So what I should really have
done is exaggerated here.
So when the particles
are close together,
the potential in the
region between the nuclei
doesn't go as close to 0
as it does when we do this.
And so that's an important fact.
So as the particles
are brought together,
something happens in
this intermediate region.
And when they're
completely separated,
it's as if they are
completely separated.
They're not talking
to each other.
And the wave functions
look like this.
I missed.
And this is what
I was telling you.
This is a bond.
This is why we have a bond.
Because we have
constructive interference
in the spatial region
where the electron can
be attracted to both nuclei.
Whereas here, there is no
amplitude in between them
or negligible
amplitude, and so there
isn't much of a contribution
from the attraction
to both nuclei.
And so this is the separated
atom or approaching separated
atom limit.
And this is the molecular limit.
And now it's
possible that you can
squeeze the atoms
too close together
and bad things start to happen.
Because then what
you're doing is you're
putting two electrons into
the same spin orbital.
And we know that that's
overlap repulsion
or it violates the
exclusion principle
and there is an energy
penalty that you
pay in order to get too close.
But basically, this is what
we're going to be explaining.
And we're going to recover
this from a real calculation.
OK.
So again, we want to
minimize the average energy.
And the average energy,
as I've written somewhere,
is given by psi star H psi
d tau psi star psi d tau.
And if we are
writing these things
as C1 1S A times
C2 1S B, then we
end up getting stuff that we
know how to calculate now.
1S A. This orbital is
not orthogonal to 1S B.
It can't be.
And so this is
something that we had
been able to avoid in all of
our one dimensional problems.
We could always think about
a orthonormalized basis set.
But the effect that we're
really interested in
is based on the fact that
these guys aren't orthogonal.
You can't just say we're going
to write an orthonormal basis
set.
It's not possible.
If you want to construct
an orthonormal basis set,
there is a transformation
you can do.
And it's a simple
transformation,
and it's done all the time.
And you'll see
it, but not today.
But you still do
the calculations
on the non-orthogonal
basis functions.
And then you do a transformation
that takes into account
the lack of orthonormality.
For now just accept it.
And so we're going to have
to worry about an integral
like this one.
SA 1 SB.
And we call this the
overlap integral.
And this is something that
we have to not ignore.
So now we can approach this
problem using wave function
notation.
And it's most familiar.
But we can also use these
things saying, OK, this
is the complete set of the
variational coefficients.
And this is a step towards
the matrix picture.
Because it's basically a linear
array of mixing coefficients.
And you could think
of that as a vector.
And in fact, that's how
you do the vector picture,
but we'll use sort of a hybrid
notation for the time being.
But we can also say,
OK, this means C1 C2 Cn.
And this means C1 star Cn star.
And here we are in
the matrix picture.
OK, but I will use sort
of a hybrid picture
until you're ready to
take the complete jump.
And so the average
energy expressed
as a function of this
set of coefficients
is going to be integral.
Psi C star H psi C d tau
over integral psi C star psi.
The reason I'm
being hesitant here
is because I work in
the matrix picture,
and this hybrid picture is
away from both comfort zones.
But it is leading you
towards what you need to see,
and so we're going to do it.
OK.
So in the wave function
picture, this thing
becomes just C1
1S A plus C2 1S B,
the whole thing conjugated,
H C1 1S A C2 psi 1S B d tau.
And the same sort of thing down
here, except no Hamiltonian.
And so we can now
slavishly write down
all of the terms
that result. And what
we get is from the
Hamiltonian matrix element.
So for H, we get C1 star
C1 H11 plus C1 star C2
H1 H12 plus C2 star C1
H21 plus C2 star C2 H22.
OK, we think we know some stuff.
We think this is going to be
the energy of the hydrogen atom.
But it isn't.
Because the orbital
one sees both nuclei.
And so this is something
which we just call this guy.
We're calling this epsilon.
And that is a function
of internuclear distance.
But this guy is the same,
because it's homonuclear.
And this, well, we
can call it V12 or V.
And these two guys
are the same thing.
So we've reduced the problem
to a simple equation.
But I'm not going to
go all the way there.
But you know how to do this.
You know how to do
the overlap integral.
You're gonna have a
similar sort of thing.
S11 is the overlap of the
orbital 1 with itself.
And that one is 1.
But S12 is S.
So anyway, what we end up
doing is a lot of algebra.
And what we end up getting
when we impose the condition
that the partial of everything
with respect to C1 star
is equal to 0, we
get an equation
for the average energy.
And the average energy is--
oh, I'm sorry.
C1.
When we take the derivative
with respect to C1, what we get
is this equation.
C1 star H11 plus C2 star H22
over C1 star S11 plus C2 star
S21.
And so we could also
do the same thing,
taking the partial
derivative with respect to C2
and setting that equal to 0.
But we get another equation.
And so that other equation
would be E average is equal to--
no, I'm not even
going to write it,
because I didn't
write it in my notes,
and I'm operating on batteries.
You can write that.
And so we have two equations
for the average energy.
And well, that's kind of good,
because we have two unknowns.
So we're going to be
able to solve for them.
OK.
Now, we could also approach this
problem using matrix methods.
And since that's the
way computers think
about the problem and that's
the way most people think
about the problem, you really
want to understand the matrix
picture.
And at risk of
repeating myself, we
know for this two level problem,
we have H11 H12 H21 H22.
And we know that the S
matrix S11 S12 S21 S22.
So we have an equation
C1 star C2 star
times the H matrix is equal to
E average times the C1 star C2
star times the S matrix.
So this is the H matrix
and this is the S matrix.
And you can write this down.
And when you take the
derivatives with respect to C,
you get C dagger H is equal
to E average times C dagger S.
Now, if instead of taking
derivatives with respect
to the Cs we took the
to the C stars, we'd get
a different equation.
And that equation would be HC is
equal to E average times S then
C. This guy looks familiar.
It looks like Hamiltonian
times something
is equal to the energy times--
uh oh.
We have something else here.
It's not just the energy.
We have the overlap integral.
So these two things are examples
of the general eigenvalue
equation.
And so in almost
all calculations,
the fact that S is present
leads to problems of algebra.
But in this particular problem,
we know S12 is equal to S21.
And this epsilon
parameter can be--
so we have H11 is equal to H22.
They're both parametrically
dependent on internuclear
distance, and they're
equal to epsilon of R.
So what we end up with
is an equation that
looks really familiar.
We have a 2 by 2 matrix,
which we can diagonalize.
We can find the energies.
And so what you end up
getting when you do that.
And I want to spare
you my attempting
to do a derivation in real time.
You can look at
the notes and you
can see that the results
are what you care about
and what we're
going to interpret.
So here we go.
So what you find.
The average energy for one
of the orbitals that we get.
Remember, we got a 2 by 2.
We're going to have two
eigenvalues and eigenstates.
And so for one of those, we
get epsilon plus V12 1 plus S1.
So these are symbols
that we've seen.
And this tells us
now this, this,
and this are functions
of R. So we're
going to have an energy for
the sigma orbital, which
is a function of R.
And we have another solution,
which we're calling sigma star.
And that one is epsilon
minus V12 over 1 minus S12.
So we'd like to be able
to know which of these is
the absolute-- one of these is--
so we have sigma and sigma star.
Both as a function
of R. And so if we
draw a molecular orbital diagram
and we say, OK, well here we
have the energy of 1SA, which
is epsilon as a function of R.
And this is epsilon energy 1SB,
which is equal to epsilon of R.
Normally we choose R
as equal to infinity
for the separated atom.
So these are actually
just the energies
of the individual orbitals.
And what we end up getting is
a molecular orbital diagram
which, in an exaggerated
form, is like this.
We get bonding,
because it's more
stable than the separate
atoms, and anti-bonding,
which is less stable.
And so one question
we'd like to ask is,
well, one question
is why is it bonding?
Why is this more stable?
And the answer is
constructive interference
in the important energy region.
But another question
is, is this bigger?
Is this a larger destabilization
than this stabilization?
And it's kind of hard
to scope that out,
because here we have two
parameters, which are added,
and here we have a
difference of two parameters.
And here we have a
denominator, which
is going to be larger
for the sigma orbital
than the sigma star.
And so we don't know whether
the plus versus minus V
is dominant.
But the energy
denominator is saying,
yeah, this one, the
anti-bonding orbital
is more anti-bonding
than the bonding one.
Now, you can actually
do some algebra
to calculate what is
the difference in energy
between the sigma star
as a function of R.
But evaluated at R sub
E, which is the minimum--
the energy where the bonding
orbital has its minimum energy.
Then if you evaluate at
that particular value of R
and you make that comparison
B 1S evaluated at R sub B,
and you get epsilon
times S12 minus--
so I'm doing sigma
star, so that's
this one minus B12 over
1 plus 1 minus S12.
And for the sigma orbital,
I have a similar equation,
but I get epsilon S12
minus B12 over 1 minus S12.
So we have the same
numerator for these two cases
but a different denominator.
And so this is saying this
simple variational calculation
says you're going to get a
pair of orbitals, one bonding,
one anti-bonding.
And the anti-bonding
one is more destabilized
relative to the
separate atoms then
the bonding one is stabilized.
And this is a kind of
general expectation
that the anti-bonding
orbitals are
more destabilized
than the bonding ones.
But it's not a proof,
because its just a proof
for the simplest possible case.
So I'm done.
And in the next
lecture, we're going
to use molecular orbital
diagrams like this
to describe a
series of examples.
Homonuclear diatomic molecules,
heteronuclear AH, and AB.
H is special, and
this is more general.
And what we'd like
to be able to do
is without a great
deal of thought
construct the molecular
orbital diagram
for basically any diatomic
molecule using some insight.
Now, this also transfers
to polyatomic molecules.
And it's especially
beautiful the way
it transfers, because
electronic structure is usually
centered at a particular
part of the molecule.
And so, basically, you're
reducing polyatomic molecules
to a diatomic that you
understanding the bonding
and anti-bonding.
OK, so I'll continue on Monday.
And your problem set for
this week is due on Monday.
And the following
set for the next week
will also be due on Monday.
Not that Monday.
The following Monday.
And that's the next to
the last problem set.
So you're inside
of the home base.
OK, have a good weekend.